you
my name is sin on a roll I'm a professor
at the NYU Stern School of Business and
at MIT and for the last 10 or 12 years
I've been studying social networks large
graphs and doing data mining on them and
in particular I focus on how information
moves through social networks and how
behaviors spread in social networks so
that jargony terms for for what I'm
talking about our virality and word of
mouth how information is moving and what
makes things go viral and today I want
to talk in particular about two things
which are social contagions in networks
and causality the importance of
separating correlation from causation in
estimates of word-of-mouth and social
contagion in networks and I want to
start with the story of a particular
tweet that was tweeted recently that's
been getting a lot of attention and no
it's not the tweet that you're probably
thinking about frankly if we didn't talk
about tweener gate ever again it would
be too soon I'm actually talking about
this tweet by keith urban on may first
and so on may first keith tweeted i'm
told by a reputable person that they've
killed Osama bin Laden and at the time
that Keith tweeted this tweet he wasn't
the first person to be speculating about
Osama bin Laden's death and he wasn't
particularly influential by any
definition of influencer or influential
that I've seen at any data mining
conference or social networking
conference at the time that he tweeted
this he had about 300 followers but
after he tweeted this it created a
Twitter cascade that looked like this
okay of tweets and retweets and
forwarding of his of his tweet and so I
studied these types of of networks and
these beautiful visualizations help us
understand sort of how information and
behavior are moving from person to
person in a social network and when
people see this kind of a visualization
they immediately think to themselves wow
you know do my tweet cascades look like
that too and I can say with confidence
that they don't you're your tweet
cascades and mine look more like
this and we know now in data that
approximately ninety nine percent of
ninety-nine percent of all cascades on
Twitter have a depth less than one okay
and that's not terrible news because
they're about a billion tweets per week
so that's about 10 million tweets that
are spreading and so I study the process
of how these types of information and
behavior spread in these social networks
and it's not just about online behaviors
right so if you think about it our word
is our world is very social and peer
influence is a big part of how we make
decisions in our lives if you ever wear
a smoker you might remember the first
cool kid in school that sort of got you
interested in smoking down by the under
the bleachers and if you ever then quit
smoking you probably know someone in
your life very close to you either part
of your family or a friend that got you
to quit smoking and in fact all of the
decisions we make in our lives are
subject to some form of peer influence
and socialization and so I study that
process because I believe that if we can
understand how behavior spread in a
social network and thus in a population
from person to person to person to
person that we could potentially promote
behaviors like these condom use exercise
or financial responsibility at Norton
was just talking about gerald charitable
giving and if you want to if you want to
collaborate with me on making charitable
giving go viral it's not just about
promoting these kinds of positive
behaviors I think that we can also
contain negative behaviors like smoking
or dirty needle sharing and so I mine
massive social networks and because I'm
at a business school one of the obvious
applications of this kind of scientific
research is in understanding how our
social environment drives our consumer
demand our purchasing decisions and so
Wired's cover in the UK not so long ago
was about social commerce and this was
the headline commerce gets social how
your networks are drive
what'd you buy so how does observing
people liking a product affect your
likelihood of purchasing that product
what about referrals by friends that are
made through social networks how does
that affect your consumer demand so I
mine massive social network data to
understand how peers influence each
other to do everything from buy a
product vote for a different political
candidate or take an HIV test and one of
the most important scientific endeavors
in this is causal statistical estimation
so I have this cartoon on my door in my
office and it's two friends talking and
one princess to the other I used to
think correlation implied causation then
I took a statistics class and now I
don't and the friend says it sounds like
the class helped and the guy goes well
maybe and the idea here is that maybe
this guy has a proclivity for
understanding statistics and interest in
statistics and so select into the
statistics class creating the
correlation between taking the class and
knowing about statistics and the class
isn't teaching him all that much about
statistics or more as much as the
average person okay and so in network
science this is known as the reflection
problem so we have abundant evidence now
that human behaviors tend to cluster in
network space and in time and the real
question is is this because of peers
influencing one another or alternative
explanations and let me give you an
example so in 2007 Nicholas Christakis
and James Fowler published this really
good study in the New England Journal of
Medicine about obesity being contagious
and what this study showed was that body
mass index increases are correlated over
time amongst friends okay so you had
pockets of obese people and pockets of
skinny people and this was picked up by
the collective unconscious and the media
and you got these news stories like this
one in the New York Times Magazine front
page cover are your friends making you
fat okay and that is a very causal
statement right so we have evidence of
correlation among obesity and body mass
index increases and then we have claims
of causation that your friends are
making you fat but there could be
alternative
nations that explain this correlation
like himali and what hemali means is
very simple birds of a feather flock
together okay we tend to make friends
with people who are like ourselves and
we know this now there's abundant
evidence on this and so if we tend to
make friends with people who are like
ourselves marathon runners might become
friends with marathon runners and those
people who like the all-you-can-eat line
at buffet at Denny's might become
friends and this would cause pockets of
obesity and pockets of less obesity in
the network and this could also explain
the correlation in obesity over time in
a social network and this is not new
news okay this was originally this quote
birds of a feather flock together was
originally attributed to Robert Burton
in the 1500s but it's even older than
that because before Robert Burton it was
Aristotle who was saying that people
love those who are like themselves and
before Aristotle it was Plato who was
saying similarity baguettes friendship
and just to prove to you that a long
line of worthy scholars have made this
argument it was my mom who said hanging
out with a bad crowd will get you into
trouble and she wasn't too pleased when
I told her that she might have gotten
the causal structure of that sentence
reversed she wasn't really happy about
that so slate ran an article which was
titled everything is contagious which
was ironically about the contagion
amongst academics to publish contagion
studies so it's not just that obesity is
contagious but apparently happiness is
contagious and product adoption is
contagious and cooperation is contagious
and the one that I have the hardest time
figuring out loneliness is contagious
not exactly sure how that works but
there could be alternative explanations
besides causal peer influence for these
results like the reflection problem or
birds of a feather flock together or
confounding factors so confounding
factors are just that friends who are
linked together in a social network tend
to be exposed to the same external
stimuli maybe they work together and the
office has a promotion on health
benefits or maybe they live in the same
neighborhood and a new all-you-can-eat
buffet opens up down the street so there
are other
explanations for this this these results
now the reason this is important is for
two reasons the causal structure of the
underlying dynamic process of the spread
of a behavior through a social network
implies different diffusion properties
for the behavior where is it going to go
next so who should we target if we're
intending to promote or contain this
behavior and it implies different
optimal containment or promotion
policies different policies will succeed
depending on the correct estimation of
separating correlation from causation so
we studied a network that was generously
given to us the data was given to us by
Yahoo and it was 30 million people
interacting over instant messenger daily
for about six months and we combined
this network data with data on a product
that was being launched over this
network and observe the day-by-day
adoption of the product in this network
and we got this data in order to devise
new statistical techniques to separate
peer influence and contagion on one hand
from confounding factors and hemali on
the other and what we found was that
that in this network if we had
attributed all of the correlation to
peer influence we would have
overestimated peer influence by up to
seven hundred percent and that fifty
percent of the contagion was really just
observable homophily correlated
preferences amongst friends and I tell
this result to my friends and I'm like
you know this results seven hundred
percent you know fifty fifty percent and
they go wow sin on you are a big nerd
you know I mean who cares seven hundred
percent fifty percent this sounds really
scientific why should it matter and I
tell them that the reason it matters is
because the policy you use depends on
getting that estimation correct in the
first place so let me give you an
example if i gave you a data set of a
behavior that was correlated in a
network over time be it HIV testing
smoking charitable giving product
adoption etc and in one case i told you
that ninety percent of the correlation
amongst friends in adopting this
behavior was because of peer influence
and ten percent was because of family
and in the second case it was the
reverse ninety percent was because of
homophily and ten percent was because of
peer influence in the first case where
peer influence ruled you would want to
adopt a peer-to-peer strategy you would
want to try to get people to bring their
friends to the behavior by giving them
incentives to do peer referrals etc in
the second strategy you would in the
second case you would just want to adopt
a traditional strategy of market
segmentation based on observable
demographic characteristics which
themselves will be correlated amongst
friends and target people who are likely
to adopt or not adopt the behavior and
so the the yahoo study was limited for
two reasons the first was because it was
about an already existing product and
the second was because it was
observational data and really the holy
grail of causal estimation of this kind
of peer influence is randomized trials
so we built a platform for conducting
randomised trials amongst millions of
people on the web and we asked a more
advanced question which is forget
plopping a viral marketing strategy on
top of an existing product can we design
the original product to go viral in the
design phase and so we looked at a
couple of specific features that you
could add to a product personal
invitations and passive awareness and
think about personal invitations like if
I gave half the people in this room the
ability to invite their friends to the
next work conference next year and I
gave the other half of the room t-shirts
that said that they went to next work
which of these two would be more
effective at generating peer influence
on their friends to come to the
conference next year and what we found
was that indeed personal invitations
were about three times more persuasive
than the passive awareness campaign and
this makes sense it's about persuading
your friend individually however even
though personal invitations nearly
doubled the contagion in the population
that we studied the passive awareness
created much more adoption of the
behavior and the reason is because more
people saw those messages even though
those messages were left less effective
per message but it's even more
complicated than that because indeed it
was the
personal invitations that resulted in
more people engaging with the behavior
over time rather than just adopting it
and churning away so in the last session
we saw that it's not just about adopting
the behavior but we want to create a
sustained adoption of the behavior over
time and personal invitations were much
more effective at doing that and so what
we found in this study was actually that
there's a virtuous cycle in viral
product design that when you create more
peer adoption it creates more engagement
and when you create more engagement it
generates more messages and personal
invitations which creates more peer
adoption which creates more peer
engagement etc and whenever I show this
result in an audience like this I can
immediately tell who the marketers are
because they start to sort of lean
forward in their seats a little bit but
it's not just about business it's not
just about selling products we're
applying the same science to HIV testing
in Africa how can we get friends to
convince their friends to take an HIV
test what are the optimal incentive
policies that will generate this
behavior and I'll leave you with a final
result because it's not just about the
influence of individuals in a social
network but it's also the susceptibility
of influence of people to influence from
their friends so we conducted a
randomized experiment among 1.4 million
people on Facebook and we were trying to
measure how different people were
susceptible to messages from their peers
and we did this on the dimension of your
relationship status okay so single in a
relationship engaged married and it's
complicated and what we found were that
single people were indeed more
susceptible to influence than people who
didn't report their relationship status
people who are in a relationship were
even more susceptible to influence than
single people people who were engaged
were even more susceptible to peer
influence than people who were in a
relationship and people who were married
were not susceptible to peer influence
at all apparently and if it was
complicated that they were the most
susceptible to peer influence apparently
and so my colleagues and I debate what
is going on here and so if you would
like to discuss any of these findings
with me I encourage you to come talk to
me
at the break but more importantly tell
your friends to come talk to me thank
you